actors get paid to show up but actually
doing the job costs extra
acting is a perilous job sometimes
whether it be stunts gone wrong actors
injuring actors or improvisations
working a little too well these moments
can wind up in the final takes and we're
taking a look at some of tv's hottest
shows right now with the help of a stunt
coordinator let's dive in
number one florence pew would kick butt
on an episode of hot ones in hawkeye
they threw the script out for the scene
where elena confronts kate but the only
reason yelena got all the hot sauce was
that florence pew loved the stuff
whereas hayley steinfeld is not such a
huge fan and elena had to be able to
keep up with the heat take after take
after take i love hot sauce
number two tanner's got mary wrapped
around his little finger
that thumb grab during the prom scene in
cobra kai season 4 is definitely not how
you pull off the move and the actors
know it you're holding on to his thumb
merry mouser had to grab tanner
buchanan's thumb and not his wrist
because she dislocated her own thumb
just minutes earlier and my thumb would
pop this happened after peyton list
landed on her hand holding somebody's
thumb is not as threatening as they made
it seem that's for sure
number three a macro reaction to a micro
or
um
cat's laugh out loud reaction to the
micro you-know-what in euphoria was
genuinely barbie's response she hadn't
wanted to look it up before the moment
so that her reaction could be as
authentic as possible it's not small
it's not small but just so you're all
aware it was just a prosthetic and if
you need even more reassurance there was
an intimacy coordinator on set and
barbie was more than willing saying they
explained to me what i was doing they
asked me if i was comfortable with it
i'm not skeeved out good to know
number four did anybody forget that the
cast of stranger things is mostly kids
millie bobby brown collapsing in this
scene in the sauna episode was not
planned for and she had to be caught by
her co-star mike wheeler who plays finn
she collapsed out of absolute exhaustion
due to consistent and long filming days
you can even see mike look over to the
director unsure of what to do though but
don't worry she was okay and it resulted
in a very tender moment between the two
characters
number five only having one fork ensures
that the dishes get done it's basic math
in hawkeye yelena complaining about
there only being one fork in kate's
apartment was totally genuine you have
one fork
i'm one person the crew had only stalked
one fork in the drawer now whether that
was intentional or they didn't expect a
whole mac and cheese halfsies situation
is up for debate sets are more than just
sets they're environments that need to
feel lived in for reasons like this full
of forks
number six you couldn't pay us enough to
go in there the last day of filming for
euphoria season one took place in a
mental hospital that was shut down due
to some incredibly unfortunate
circumstances where 40 groundskeepers
lost their lives it freaked out the
entire cast namely sydney sweeney who
said it was the creepiest place that
i've ever been to and we were filming
there all day and all night that didn't
stop them from exploring though even in
the creepy basement that was completely
devoid of lights number seven we're
still upset about it in stranger things
millie's first time reading hopper's
letter happened on camera so those big
crocodile tears were totally genuine and
yes they got us too millie admitted i
didn't want to rehearse it i just
immediately wanted to put a camera on me
and find the way i react and the way i
reacted was pure devastation and sadness
what made the scene even harder to film
was that david harbor recorded himself
reading the letter so millie was hearing
his voice at the same time it's giving
us all the feels
time to go number eight show don't tell
that's a screenwriting lesson for you
the cast and crew were very quickly
losing daylight while trying to film
meaning they didn't have enough time to
capture the entire scripted dialogue
between clint and kate in this scene
instead the two were just asked to walk
away from the camera but that wasn't
good enough for jeremy renner who
decided to pull an arrow out of kate
bishop's bag which confused hayley
steinfeld in the filming he proceeded to
pass her the arrow them holding onto the
arrow at the same time is iconic because
it comes straight out of one of the
comics
number nine you could say this is the
straw that breaks the camel's back when
gehen barrels into sebiuk in the first
episode of squid game he knocks her
drink out of her hand what made her
break down laughing though was when the
actor tried putting the straw back into
the drink they got lucky that they were
able to use the shot at all since
sabjuk's hair covered her laugh that's
one good reason to have long hair
number 10 can you guess where this one
is going brett gilman was super quick
with the double entendres and stranger
things which made it hard to film with
him jonathan
that was the pull out
that spit take of charlie heaton's very
much real he meant the sofa you
dirty-minded kids
number 11. when you know the material
inside and out it makes you a good
advocate for the material henry cavill a
lover of the series before ever taking
on the role was upset about a missing
beat from one of the books blood of
elves geralt is supposed to have a brush
with death at the top of sodom hill
there's a monolith with all of the
soldiers who've passed this wasn't
included so he took it upon himself to
improvise a line that would pay homage
to the scene after we tragically lose
roach he helps the horse on his journey
by saying the words to not be afraid of
she or she is your friend
number 12 cold showers are bad enough
francesco reale the actor who played the
lifeguard heather in season three of
stranger things was terrified of filming
in the pool because she couldn't see the
bottom or anything for that matter due
to it being pitch black that would scare
any sane person
number 13 dude just let your stunt
double step in in an episode of cobra
kai billy zabka kicked martin cove's
foot so he was hiding a whole lot of
pain during one scene as he broke his
toe and wasn't telling anybody for fear
of his stunt double having to step in so
he's hobbling around secretly in so much
pain and we won't reveal how he
described it it hurts too much to
remember just trust us it's something
you don't forget
number 14 words are hard especially with
a camera in your face improv isn't easy
and so this scene where finn is
struggling to tell eleven how he feels
doubles as the actor just trying to come
up with his next line sometimes the most
genuine of moments can't be scripted
it's like a feeling or yeah like
something
number 15. in riverdale that red stuff
coming out of kj apa's hand was not done
by some special effect he was so
intensely invested in the scene that he
was beating up the ice to the point he
ended up breaking his hand from punching
it so hard
number 16 can we please make jump scares
illegal is that something we can do
during the filming of the haunting of
hill house victoria padretti who plays
nell and of course the ghost of nell as
well jumped her q and scared the pants
off of kate siegel and elizabeth reeser
genuine jump scares are always a better
idea despite how much actors must hate
them but we're wondering if she's just
being cheeky and pretending it was an
accident
number 17 a beautiful dedication to a
good man the gut-wrenching tears that
the characters cried at fred andrews
funeral in riverdale were not put on due
to the tragic passing of luke perry who
played the role the scene was done in
dedication to him making it all the more
heartbreaking it was the plot twist that
the world did not see coming and the
cast and crew of riverdale did a
beautiful job with their dedication to
luke
number 18 true story bro in an episode
of this is us ron cephas jones who plays
william randall's biological father
tells a story about a time he went for a
haircut and the barber playfully
threatened to cut off his ears as it
turns out this was a true story from
jones's past about his first time
getting a haircut
number 19. that feel when you're made up
of something like 60 water and yet
you're still afraid of it also in
riverdale madeleine petch had a serious
fear of open bodies of water so her
scene in the boat is an expression of
true terror but she had to get over that
fear quick given how early this comes in
the series
number 20 don't take massages from
strangers in new girl jake johnson who
plays nick found the idea of a water
massage super uncomfortable and he
decided to lean into his discomfort
which resulted in a lot of improvised
moments in this scene
to be fair there was a silent man
stripping down in front of him what does
this mean let's not do this number 21
the best mispronunciation in the history
of mispronunciations
shit's creaks catherine o'hara
accidentally said baby weird and
everybody loved it so much it stuck not
just in that episode but in subsequent
episodes too literally somebody made a
compilation of every time she said it
either way great progress for bebe which
honestly is hilarious now you're taking
pepe to the spa
all this talk about actors not acting
has us questioning what it even is some
say acting is lying some say it's truth
some will say method is acting and
others will say it's people looking for
an excuse to do something weird and
ridiculous let us know your thoughts on
that in the comments and maybe let us
know about any other scenes we should
have included in the video and as always
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things